Beechwood Hall is an antebellum home
near Franklin Tennessee right outside
Nashville it's one of the few buildings
of its size to survive the Civil War
it's a National Historic Landmark in the
1950s country music legend Hank Williams
bought Beechwood Hall more recently
country music stars Faith Hill and Tim
McGraw Live there last year a fund
manager from California called Larry
Keel bought the property now according
to neighbors the property is in complete
disrepair as you can see and a
non-profit that oversees historic
preservation called The Heritage
Foundation of Williamson County is
suggesting that Beechwood Hall could
soon be demolished
Keel and we're not alleging anything
here just noting happens to be a major
donor to that non-profit
so the question is how much American
history do you have to lose before you
lose the country itself in the last
years we've lost statues and monuments
and our customs
so tearing down Hank Williams's house in
Antebellum house would constitute not
just an assault on the soul of country
music a distinctly American art form it
would be an attack on the country itself
and maybe we've had enough maybe no more
kid rock appears to feel that way he is
of course a country music legend lives
in Nashville joins us tonight Kid Rock
thanks so much for coming on so you have
your own house why are you interested in
this house and what happens to it
I think like so many other people in
this country we're sick of seeing
history tore to the ground whether it be
in the form of Monument statues and now
something so important here in Nashville
like the former home of Hank Williams
Beechwood Hall I also might note it was
also the former home of Tim McGraw and
Faith Hill
um you know where does this end we kind
of all knew that from the beginning once
this Fiasco started that it was never
going to end and now we kind of feel
like we're under an invasion from the
state of California which we understand
in a lot of ways I have a lot of friends
here that come from these spots
California New York City
um and this is kind of in a house
because you know we feel that a lot of
people say it and they say it under
their breath but they're scared to say
it out loud so once again I'll be the
guy
is you know they come here leaving these
woke policies from these cities you know
for better schools lower taxes lower
crime we've talked about that you've
talked about a million times and uh we
kind of tell them leave your
F and politics at the state this is what
you're coming
and this is just one more example of
somebody from California who As I
understood gave a handshake and to
people in the community and through this
Foundation that is a donor for and now
he basically is
seems like another Avenue to tear it
down and I don't think there's anything
more important in country music if not
American Music than Hank Williams
yeah the greatest songwriter of all
times and I think great songwriters
would be an ingredient
so can I just ask I mean we don't know
the motive and we don't have this man on
the show tonight but why would you move
to a new place and then want to tear
down its history doesn't that seem kind
of a weird thing to do
yeah we call dumb liberals
yeah
well that's that's one explanation said
Hank Williams this is I think that's
fair that's fair
um that says it all so this Hank
Williams is is if there's an icon in
Nashville it's Hank Williams okay so is
Nashville as a right exactly and this
was his former property so as a
community or is Nashville rising up
against this to preserve this historic
property are you the only one
I think uh well I'm kind of you know
thanks to you and uh and people that
care about these things I've just kind
of become the person to put it out there
so I don't I think now that now that
you're broadcasting the story to uh all
of America I think there's going to be
many many people to get on board they
can go to savebeachwood.org and I think
you're going to see a lot more uh
country music stars musicians just uh
great people in the community that want
to preserve this for the Next Generation
to come Generations beyond that well
exactly I mean we both believe in
private property of course and defend it
but there are some monuments that aren't
really yours you're they're custodian
you know you hold them till the till the
next Generation comes and this sounds
like one of them I appreciate it when
you say when you come in when you come
into it with a handshake kind of thing
and say I'm going to preserve this and
then you start weaseling around to do
other things you know we hope to get
this resolved and you know in a good
manner but if not we can we can get some
hillbilly we've gone on too
well I'll leave that to you to solve but
thank you for bringing this to our
attention the country's lost so much of
its history how about no more great to
see you Kid Rock
we've got a documentary on that man
called life for Rockstar Kid Rock it's
on Fox Nation subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube channel to catch our nightly
opens stories that are changing the
world and changing your life from Tucker
Carlson tonight